la circuncisión es la extirpación
quirúrgica del prepucio del pene de un
bebé varón por lo general se realiza en
los primeros días tras el nacimiento
al nacer el pene tiene una funda
protectora de tejido llamada prepucio
que cubre el glande o cabeza el prepucio
generalmente se puede retraer para dejar
expuesto el glande del pene al llegar a
la pubertad
según la academia estadounidense de
pediatría los beneficios potenciales que
tiene la circuncisión para la salud
incluyen facilita la limpieza del pene
disminuye el riesgo de contraer vih
infecciones de transmisión sexual
infecciones de las vías urinarias y
ciertos tipos de cáncer
y previene problemas en el prepucio como
las complicaciones de la incapacidad de
retraer lo desde la punta del pene
y otros motivos frecuentes para la
circuncisión son creencias religiosas
sociales y culturales
antes del procedimiento se limpiará la
zona el profesional sanitario
administrará analgésicos ya sea en forma
de inyección o como crema adormecedora
durante el procedimiento será un pequeño
corte en el prepucio
y este se soltará de la cabeza
el profesional sanitario colocará un
dispositivo sobre el glande este
dispositivo protegerá el pene
permitiendo la extirpación del prepucio
sin complicaciones si se usa un
dispositivo de plástico el profesional
sanitario atar el prepucio al anillo
a continuación se recortará el prepucio
el anillo se dejará en su lugar
y se caerá en el plazo de 5 a 7 días
dejando la circuncisión curada
si se utiliza un dispositivo metálico de
campana el prepucio se recortará
alrededor de la base de la campana la
campana se retirará al final del
procedimiento
después del procedimiento es normal que
el glande este sensible parezca irritado
y presenta una pequeña secreción
amarillenta
si se usa un vendaje cámbielo con el
pañal
utilicé vaselina o ungüento antibiótico
para evitar que el vendaje se adhiera a
la herida
es seguro lavar el pene suavemente con
agua ya que ayuda a la cicatrización la
circuncisión debería cicatrizar por
completo en el plazo de 10 a 14 días
para obtener más información sobre la
circuncisión hablé con su proveedor de
atención sanitaria